lancement d'une grande campagne
médiatique aujourd'hui pour vanter les
bienfaits de la côte atlantique pour les
vacanciers à belle-ile-en-mer le prix de
la traverse est est cassée sur place et
commerçants font aussi de gros efforts
pour attirer la clientèle
suite aux conséquences de la marée noire
de l'erika sur les côtes bretonnes
le reportage de lmp dèche eric nezzar
embarcadères de port maria à quiberon
destination bélisle la deuxième vague de
vacanciers s'apprête à embarquer à bord
du 20 10 lice l'un des trois navires de
la société morbihannaise est nantaise de
navigation qui des services pour le coup
d'envoi de la saison touristique le
conseil général du morbihan a décidé de
donner un coup de pouce aux
professionnels de belle-ile groix houat
et hoëdic en abaissant le prix des
traversées de 30%
nous pensons que fab devrait donner à un
coup de fouet supplémentaire avant la
saison aux gens qui aiment bélisle et
peut-être voudraient venir en famille ne
serait ce que pour voir comment on a
bien nettoyé les ce sera en conseil
général de rembourser le manque à gagner
à la compagnie maritime le département
dable sur environ 3 millions de francs
cet effort financier portera-t-il ses
fruits en ces premiers jours de vacances
le 20/10 fait le plein de touristes qui
de toute façon avait décidé de faire la
traversée
cette passion bélisle malgré la marée
noire bas on vient toujours parce qu'on
est fidèle
il faut venir c'est tellement beau
bélisle ça fait longtemps que je rêve
d'y aller quoi et puis là ça se réalise
quoi donc son temps sur l'île
la saison est désormais lancée pour
tenter de reconquérir des touristes peut
être découragée par les images de plages
mazoutées certains professionnels ont
eux aussi consenti à faire un petit
geste
les loueurs de vélos ainsi que word de
scooters et autres ont maintenu leurs
prix comme les autres années donc je
pense que nécessairement l'effort a été
fait voilà une semaine que les liaisons
maritimes entre lille et continent
bénéficient de ces tarifs promotionnels
mais il faudra attendre le 15 juin pour
mesurer les retombées de cette offre sur
la fréquentation dans les îles